it to start a movement from scratch is
obviously very very difficult but it's
very important to examine and reexamine
your own convictions as a part of that
movement or an as an instigator of that
movement for instance Ayatollah Khomeini
who is credited with the Iranian
Revolution of 1979 it was legitimate at
the time to protest against the
oppression of the shower and he had
thought things through and he came up
with Islam is the solution we have to
get rid of anything that is Western and
foreign we have to go back to our roots
and Islamic sharia is the answer people
who are that I may not have agreed with
him but who had more hatred toward the
Shah than they had rationally thought
through what how many was saying was
swept by that feeling that there is
something new on the horizon and it's
attractive and it's familiar if only in
those years they had thought a little
longer if only those individuals had
spent time thinking about but am I
really convinced that divine law is the
answer to our to our society of Iranian
problems it is very important to examine
yourself and and develop a Creed develop
a year not only a narrative but also a
practical way to getting to the vision
that you hold it's not enough to say no
to the bad guy human history is full of
revolutions that never materialized
where the oppressive regime is
overthrown and whatever follows
sometimes is worse you where you get
other case you get blood shirt you get a
new form of oppression so people engaged
in social and political reform and
sometimes revolution have to think
through what the next step is what is
going to come after the fall of Morella
what is going to come after the fall of
the Saudi monarchy what do we want to
put in place these are very very
difficult answers because most people
don't agree on what that outcome should
be it's easier to agree on getting rid
of the bad guy